[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos this is my chat
with my pal mike o'gorman one of the
funniest people alive one of the best
impressionists alive and this uh this
episode is filled with impressions which
you know i absolutely love and then also
some really thoughtful and interesting
engaging stuff as well so i hope you
enjoy it only a couple things to plug up
top september 8th is my next show here
in los angeles at largo go to largo
l-a-r-g-o-l-a
dot com for tickets that is my live
stand-up show i do it once a month it's
always incredible uh recently we've had
melanie's come by amy schumer's come by
judd apatow
bo burnham did it one time phoebe
bridgers did it one time there's music
as well
it's always always always incredible
some of my favorite people do it every
single time val is usually there uh
almost always there and it's the
highlight of my month i hope you can
make it whenever you hear this episode
uh go to
largodashla.com and look at the calendar
for pete holmes living at largo the next
one is september 8
and if you like this show why not try it
pete's pick only one pizza pick to
mention up top here and it's my friends
at magic mind magic mind i think if i
were to say the one product that's
changed my life in the biggest way
in such a small bottle it would be magic
mine for sure it has changed my
relationship to work to productivity and
to my brain magic mind is not an energy
drink it is a productivity drink in fact
it's the world's first productivity
drink it's a magical elixir that makes
you focus better on your work be more
creative and drink less coffee it has
adaptogens in it which round out the
edges if you take this with your coffee
it rounds out the edges and sort of
smooths out the caffeine not making you
so jolty but giving you energy and
rounding out the energy you're getting
from your coffee as well
magic mind on its own has about 35
milligrams of caffeine
which comes from matcha which as you
know matcha is a nice rounded even
caffeine so it's not like a wired drink
it's a dialed in drink i take it before
i go on stage before i write before i
work before i have to answer emails it
gives you about five to seven hours of
flow state
and i find it incredibly mood elevating
not just energy but like feeling like
your brain has shown up
uh so it's not just like oh wake up and
shock yourself back to life with
thousands of milligrams of caffeine it's
not that it's productivity
in a bottle uh this is one line i like
to say creators have creator aid like
athletes have gatorade this is creator
aid it is the creator's best friend
helps fight off procrastination brain
fog fatigue and some symptoms of add
getting you into that flow state after
three to seven days of continuous use
it's even easier to get into that flow
state and with a money-back guarantee
any first purchase will be refunded no
questions asked if it doesn't meet your
expectations and i actually have an
offer for uh weirdos from our friends at
magic mind all you have to do is go to
dot magic mind dot co who has time for
the full com magic mind dot co slash
weird and use discount code weird to get
twenty percent off that's a limited
twenty percent off your first order val
swears by it i swear by it i keep it in
my travel bag i keep some in my car
anytime i'm doing something where i need
to get into that flow state and just
focus but also feel that elation and
that happiness honestly this like mood
elevation that helps me ease into what
i'm doing i swear swear swear by magic
mind it is a true pete speck i reached
out to them
uh after i was using them for weeks and
now we have the promo code so i hope you
like it as much as i do and if you want
to give it a try and support the show
magicmind.comweird and weird at checkout
all right guys that's it hope to see you
at largo on september 8th or any other
month it's always wonderful to have
weirdos there and in the meantime enjoy
my chat with the hilarious
mike o gorman
get into it that's you buddy
and as i always say
um and can i get my coffee please it's
it's that we can
it's a can full of wee
yeah yeah coffee from yesterday
so i'll drink a coffee from yesterday
will you sure
have you seen
this is good this is you know what i
love about this are we rolling yeah
we're rolling because this is when i
listen to podcasts and they're like are
we rolling and you go how the [__] do
you not know that you're rolling what do
you tell me you mean they should know
because they're in a studio and you're
holding a mic they're like
this is this are we on
yeah
i think the old but now i get it because
i just came in and here we are yeah yeah
that's right now you've seen yeah you've
seen the understanding
there's a i think the old way was of
course you're not rolling right because
you'd be smoking cigarettes like johnny
carson and yeah you'd be saying like
inappropriate like slurs and stuff and
you'd be like yeah check out the gams on
that dame yeah yeah man she's been doing
our cue cuts i'll have my girl call you
tomorrow exactly and then he's like well
good evening ladies and gentlemen i'm
sitting here with michael gorman like it
was more
show yes now it's more biz yeah no no
we're just going to make any a guest
house and
i mean thanks for calling it a guest
house that's an upgrade this is a raj
is it a garage i said raj oh raj okay
far cooler than me raj al ghul um is
this my water yes excellent enjoy it
thank you it's not i'm glad that you
knew that was a water and not an ice
cold beer
i mean
would you not say no to an ice cold beer
that's a beer
that's a nice cold beer just kidding
it's it is your drink you my friend are
drinking liquid death liquid death water
there were two things that have already
first of all
for real
i i like it seems like i turned on my
showbiz persona because i greeted you at
the door very casual sure yeah walked
you back i was gonna say it was very
cash super well i don't want anything i
the moment where we want to be like hey
oh my god we do that right i want all
that
right
but i want you to also know that i
didn't like kick it up a gear for the
show i'm actually like sincerely and
legitimately those all mean the same
thing very excited to see you you're one
of the funniest human beings dude alive
please i i've i felt the same way the
whole time that i've known i was going
to do this because i you know it's
we have a unique relationship in that we
don't see each other very often but when
we do it's just like the funnest
like we laugh a lot and it's great
i'm having like a a weird dream that is
my life right and you're this delightful
little
is imp bad i mean like it's like an
elfish like meaning magical like it's
like i've eaten a lot of mushrooms i pop
in when you need me and you pop in but
i'm on a quest and like my quest is just
my life i don't mean it's like a special
question i'm just kind of doing my
things and whenever i see
the anita muscaria is that what it's
called the the red with the white dots
it's a little hot and you open the door
and you're wearing an apron there's a
little blood on it because you know how
mushrooms are kind of scary sure there's
like some blood on it like there's
something kind of devilish about you
potentially sure but i always come in
and you serve me little acorn
acorn caps filled with hot tea yeah and
they're like some wine or
wine
and honeysuckle bread mm-hmm yeah and we
eat it by a tiny fire
and every single time i see you
i die laughing and i remember that
comedy thanks
comedy can be
kind of for its own sake yeah cure
yeah and and entertaining to us i think
you know i'm gonna put it to you one
final thing it's like i just feel like
when you when everybody likes pirating
but then when you become a full-time
pirate then you're kind of like yeah i
buck i swashbuckle but like it's it's my
job
like anything it gets boring after a
while it gets boring and it becomes
something that you associate with
throwing it into gear yeah or delivering
yeah and it's very rare and true
uh to have those those imps that you've
run into along the way that whenever i'm
with you i just remember that comedy is
also what we did at sleepovers yeah what
we did at birthday parties it's more of
a hangout comedy than a than it is for a
hanging comedy yeah yeah i i never feel
like i'm working when i when i'm with
you yeah which actually goes all the way
but i was gonna laugh cause two things
just came up one i was gonna say
cold coffee drinking yesterday's coffee
[Laughter]
buddy
you know where what film references
drinking cold coffee the coffee that you
leave out overnight and drink it the
next day no
this is gonna seem like i forced it but
it happened my dinner with andre
and is there anything that needs to
happen more my andre the giant
impression is your andre the dine
impression like when i did your talk
show the andre the giant show
it's on youtube right you can see it
there and that's just me sweaty and red
like i am now but it's jumping around uh
to give it some structure yeah but the
actual day was just me dying i had never
heard someone do andre the giant
i didn't even put it together that andre
the giant was french
yeah until i had heard you do it yeah
but uh i feel like the world needs my
dinner with andre the giant yeah
okay so let's i'll go because we're on a
podcast i can go into kind of the
origins of how i figured that out so in
the i would love nothing more in the
brief moment that i did stand up
what year is this this is probably like
2004 2005
actually maybe maybe more like 2005
2006. okay
i had a joke my closing in my on my
tight five or seven was my closing was
like i love movies and i love suspense
thrillers and i love when the
the kidnapper call makes that ransom
call and he's got that modulator on the
phone call and he goes
if you want to see your honor again
bring 50 000 to the
garbage can behind the supermarket we
have your color
we have your family yeah your family is
on a ski lift
your family's on a ski lifting we've
stopped the ski lift there
so good
how are you doing that we i just figured
out i could do that there's a power to
it see when i do it i go low and i lose
power
like i can't project at that yeah
there's there's gotta be a force
you have to be able to force it through
and and uh imagine being that guy but
you are just making like a dinner
reservation well that was the joke the
joke was the joke was what if he left it
on
and then calls for like chinese takeout
that's unbelievable
and it goes and it goes uh
you know and i would do the whole thing
like there's a group of guys around and
it's like
uh yeah let me get
uh
uh order of uh let me get like five egg
rolls uh
a thing of uh general chalice chicken
and then i've got a thing
what
well look at the menu because i'm on the
phone with the guy now
like his friend just walked in
[Music]
so that so i would do that joke look at
the menu yeah well hurry up i'm on the
phone i'm on the with the guy in there i
say great comedy points out something
that i feel which is the tension
of when you're making an order and and
someone coming in late you got to get
this done this like you're wasting there
too where have you been and they're
gonna [__] up the order or like they're
gonna take it out on us somehow and it's
food and it's like we're animals and
we're weird about our food absolutely
and some guy comes in and he's casual
you're in you're in a situation yeah
where were you five minutes ago and you
better pick fast yeah and the guy that
goes i'll decide by the time it comes
back around to me you better [__]
decide
or you just you'll say i'll have what
he's having yeah you better harry met
sally this [__] yeah yes hurry up katie
let's just point the fan at michael
gorman oh yeah
is it toasty roasty sorry i'm just i'm
just accommodating
i'm accommodating i appreciate it i like
it it'll be done in a second i like
being like a hot sweaty boy
like
like a memphis judge a memphis judge
your honor
if i could just please the court order
in my court please
[Laughter]
they always wear white the color that
shows sweat the most see and you can see
it's kind of white yellow yes yellowy
yes yellowy brown their their stuff has
been soiled yes it's soiled
give me a white suit i plan on sweating
quite a bit in the courtroom tomorrow
the first southern court that had air
conditioning everybody left that trial
and was like something was off i had my
kerchief
but i didn't i didn't use it a single
time and it threw my rhythm he was like
ladies and gentlemen
there's no sweat upon my bra
how how am i going to convince you of my
earnestness
and how hard i'm fighting for the
innocence of this young man
there's a drama in there's that down
what i'm saying is they say don't act
with cigarettes don't act with food
because
you become this guy you you want to do
it like it's so it slows you down yeah
now it naturalizes what you're doing
uh same for a southern lawyer don't pat
your brow let it drip let it gather on
your eyebrow yeah and then drip drip
down drip down as you're addressing like
a cliffhanger i wanted to fall
like his friend at the beginning of
cliffhanger michael rooker michael
rooker's girlfriend in the beginning of
cliffhanger you are living weed oh my
god just be with hank i was gonna say
just be with me all the time
uh i'd be happy to do that i i
appreciate that but it's also that be
with me means like be with me like have
sex and that's that's who started that
no that doesn't have to always be what
that means i completely agree and i
appreciate your yes and so we were doing
the bet you're you've got yeah right so
then i i just some somewhere along the
line i picked up that if you put a
french accent on that
then it becomes sounds rather giant
it's just a subtle french thing that
happens where
then it becomes andre
[Laughter]
it's
that day
that day i
i feel like it's important to the story
i can't say for sure
but i knew you we had done uh ugly
americans together in new york
so i knew you and i knew
sometimes uh pete's memory is smarter
than pete you know what i mean pete
might go like do i want to do something
like i don't know sure maybe i was busy
i don't even know but pete's memory goes
i seem to recall right you love being
with mike
well we had done the when we were doing
ugly americans our good buddy dan powell
had that
separate thing that he wanted to do
where it was
it was right i think before the
uh
maybe it was when the dark knight came
out and we did the christian bale or
well you're you're bringing up yes
christian bale and morgan foreign
freedom yeah yeah and what
happened on the day so dan powell had
the idea that we could try it this
almost always fails unfortunately when
you try to make a viral video yeah yeah
and it didn't end up working in that way
but he had the idea that we could make a
fake video
and say that it was leaked audio right
from the set
of the dark knight the dark knight i
think the dark knight was being filmed
at the time yeah all we knew was
christian bale and morgan freeman right
right so he was like funny enough this
was before christian bales leaked
audio from terminator salvation and
would that have happened had we not made
our video the answer is no
it's a definitive no all things being
super connected i'm going to say we made
that happen
so this is before but jay yeah that
whole thing poor guy i feel bad for
everybody
yeah i feel bad for everybody i know i i
don't mean to make this about christian
bail but when people were like what an
[__] i was like
man when you make somebody a superstar
like they're basically walking around
with the pressure
of a lot of a lot you eat what you cook
you eat what you cook
same ferocious intensity that makes him
great is also what makes him snap at
mcgee sure
who later we learned was kind of known
to be a turd that's what i heard i guess
i don't know he's actually my current
boss mcgee
no
i start filming on in september on uh
true lies for cbs and he's one of the
mick g mcgee yeah okay mick g and uh
jimmy cameron are my bosses on this show
i've never i've not met either of them
but they're my bosses james jimmy
cameron and james avatar cameron
james vegan cameron and mcgee the the
cinematographer from terminator
salvation yeah
did he direct that movie no i think he's
just a cinematographer okay and you
do the best christian bale that's of all
time you have to yell at him as
christian male 1
oh maybe i will day one if he's there he
wasn't there for the pilot but if he's
there i'll yell at him in that
because you
i was gonna say you have to start i've
never heard
i'm sorry to make this morning radio
yeah so it's the best christian bail
i've ever heard well and that comes from
in batman begins there's a scene where
he's talking to katie in the kitchen
right
and he just said this line that where i
was like oh that and it was he says to
katie holmes who plays rachel dawes in
the movie he says he's talking about the
guy who killed his parents and he goes
he goes rachel
i cannot let that pass
and he just had this he has this thing
in his mouth that where his tongue is
almost too big for his mouth
and you know you can't in and and then i
could go back and you know then you
could kind of go back and forth to the
british
and then you know you know sort of back
to american it's just
it's
it's just this tongue thing that happens
and i don't know if that sounds good in
this no it does but you would do it like
what what we did for dan powell was i
was morgan freeman and you were
christian bale and like five minutes in
i realized my morgan freeman was like
finger paint morgan freeman and i like
your nose i really appreciate it but
we were trying to do
like a conversation it was like caught
and then you'd be like we ended up
talking about sandwiches or something
like oh what do they have for lunch or
something like that it was like
i i i think somebody said sandwiches
it's sandwiches today like something
like that
well and then when you hear yours which
sounds like a real guy
yours sounds like a guy and then i'd be
like i sound like a guy doing an
impression of you
well a delicious sandwich is always good
for lunch and it's like is that how he's
like morgan freeman like for real on a
movie set probably sounds like well
great
i can't even do it right it's probably
like deeper
and then he goes and then he does his
morning when he's like the penguins go
up the hill yeah four days and seven
nights
god morgan you said four days and seven
it doesn't really work out that way you
get one take use the four from four days
and paste it over the server i'm sure i
use another number at some point in the
in the narrative in fact one two
three
four
five
six
just cut everyone waiting seven
eight
nine
zero i'm going to 37
[Laughter]
18.
he has a he has a number now i always do
37. you'll never see a movie where
morgan freeman says 38.
okay okay all right well funny enough so
we did that audio thing the christian
bale morgan freeman thing
two years later spilled coffee on my
shirt michael [__] santa at least it
wasn't yesterdays
[Laughter]
and uh so two years later we're having
about the metaphysical
really blowing my mind at least there
wasn't yesterday's coffee
[Laughter]
you do you have like a sing-songy
quality like yeah it's god's like simple
that he's like elisa wasn't yesterday's
car for you like he's just kind of like
kind of a happy-go-lucky every sentence
is a presentation sometimes with him
yeah
i've decided today to wear this hat
okay you were saying so two years later
something like that
i was i had moved here we're having i
was having
i had a friend over and he goes
the i forget what the conversation how
it started
but he goes have you ever heard that
that audio recording where they did
morgan freeman and christian bale and i
went
that's me
no he had known he knew about the thing
and he didn't know me and i was like
that's me and pete holmes no what he
believed that it was i don't think he
believed it but he was he was like he
hadn't heard it and was like
yeah there i heard this guy does a
christian or maybe i had done it and
then he was like yeah i heard this video
this thing
and he was like that's a good christian
bale too and i was like yeah because
it's me
whoa
it's the same one so what is this thing
you're doing with jim
james cameron like yeah
not to force this into the
podcast
i did a pilot in november
so cbs is doing a series version of the
movie true lies
wow and
the tom arnold guy cast
you're the schwarzenegger no no no i'm i
play like a new character but i am a spy
that works with him we're like
co-workers
and i mean it's not a spoiler to say
like in the movie
you know he struggles with joe
manganiello
who's the schwarzenegger oh hi uh steve
howie steve who you might know from
shameless okay um
and uh
in uh in the movie he's sort of arnold
is struggling with the juggling the fact
that he's a spy but he has to keep this
huge secret from his family yes he's a
family guy and uh so in the show i play
a co-worker spy
of the harry tasker character
who you know when he's sort of dealing
with this i'm the guy that's like well
he should have gotten married what a
[__] idiot like you know like i'm
sort of the class clown and like
he's they describe him as
a harmless misogynist
[Laughter]
which is what we called a man for like
most of known history yes he's a
harmless misogynist yes he hates women
yeah but he doesn't hit them
this is a win
he calls them broads he calls them games
take what you can get take away
it's a win it's a win
that's wonderful and did you meet uh
flock of seagulls cameron no no i didn't
meet he wasn't there uh nor was mick g
was
mcgee was directing a movie in atlanta
we shot in new orleans and uh so i
didn't meet them on there but we start
to i think we start shooting the series
in early september i don't know if
they'll be down there at all but and
this is a single camera
this is what if it was a multi camera it
is it's
we've lost that from the original
unfortunately and are there cutaways to
fantasies because remember in true lies
that was kind of a thing was like he'd
be test driving the car and he'd punch
the guy yeah i mean it's it's possible
we could do that there's none of that in
the pilot but uh yeah that's like not
out of the realm of possibility for this
show
you want a pilot written right
jimmy jimmy
you know there are certain we call them
mechanisms
that are established in this everyone's
blue
that's it yeah cause he's going he's
going full avatar i think he's i think
this is just an ad for avatar and that's
an adventure an avatar do you remember
when advocate
came out
and everyone thought it was
virtual jamiroquai insanity that that it
was going to be like cgi
do you remember that i remember yeah i
remember like everybody being like it's
going to be the most
like cgi
or like the the most involved
visual experience and then we had seen
dinosaurs be cgi sure and then somebody
was like no the whole thing is cgi like
there is no pandora
[Laughter]
sweetheart
you can't go to pandora it's not right i
don't know if you know this ben you want
a sheep and dorky he has a usb drive on
him just to make the point this is
pandora she's paying doors
and then and then he drives on all the
mountains
all the hills all the rivers all the
bread on this thing
then he drives home later that day and
goes [__] i should have said this is
pandora's box
is it too late to go back don't turn it
around
[Laughter]
he does a huey on the freeway goes back
yeah uh this is pandora's bag we reveal
he's talking to a skeleton what i i
don't know why
he took it he took any human form so
that's incredible so like you
strayed auditioned and booked big deal
yeah it was a it was weird because i had
i had i had like this three year drought
basically of not really doing anything
and covet and all that stuff
and so self tapes were not
a thing and i got to a point
where
my my number of auditions were not
what they had been a couple years ago
and
for various reasons and and so i reached
out to my agent i said
can you can you start sending me out on
drama
so we can cast a wider net so i could
just get out on more stuff
and that you know because you you know
this book
so why am i thinking of this
why was this my idea you know this you
get pigeonholed into these pockets of
like well you know i and i don't i never
know how to describe myself because i i
wasn't a stand-up like you i did sketch
but i be i came up there's a few words
for you
dashing
i used this i used to say just one word
i used to go you know john krasinski
yeah and i go i kind of do what he does
like i'm just like a comedic actor yeah
like i'm not a stand-up i wasn't like
krizin called his agent and was like i
want to be jack ryan right
and that works and it does work i mean
like i like it that's always been a show
that i'm like should i be watching yeah
ryan it's fun yeah
um they have the amazon has cornered the
market on all the jacks they got reacher
they got ryan
hey they got jack frost i'm talking the
michael keaton horror movie where he
plays a sociopathic snowman he comes
back to life as a snowman every movie
picture i've ever had where they're like
it doesn't seem like for us i'm like you
know someone made jack frost and then i
flick lit cigarettes at each of the
executives yes yes i have my my
assistant holding lit cigarettes that
are towards the towards the nub yeah so
i can you want it tight you want it to i
wanted to spin it right to the butt yeah
smoke it to the filter yeah yeah and hit
him in the eye ideally yes and then i
out and then i leave dvds of jack frost
no
i leave h dvds high definition video
desks you know in the black box in the
[Laughter]
the ones in the black box
they tried
what they sure did in swooped blu-ray
yep
sorry you do know we're doing a
documentary about hdb about the
transition from from h h t v to blu-ray
h
it was a it was a weird time it was a
dark time
it was a dark time
uh armageddon and deep impact uh okay so
you
were saying oh you call your agent so i
said this is a good story by the way are
you are you're in a three-year slump
this couldn't have been easy
no it was i i i wasn't getting stuff and
in covid we were doing self-tape
auditions where living alone
yeah yeah so just michael uh no i was i
was i was base i was living i was
separated from my wife at the time and i
was dating somebody else and i was
living with her basically but using my
place as like an office
so i'd come home
you mean the l.a way yeah the l.a
and um
and uh anyway so what about you just see
me like
loudly and conspicuously write down
separated from wife
but you can
[Laughter]
well as a divorce i love talking about
divorce i find it to be helpful and
interesting but we will put a pin sure
i wanted you to the little glimmer in
the home's eye when i'm like ooh
okay
a heartbreak ooh yeah more lesson
lessons were learned though
okay so you're living with your
girlfriend yeah so then so then i i and
this was kind of before covid but the
first like dramatic thing he sends me
out on is uh perry mason which was they
redid that for hbo and i get it
and first that was live that was a live
audition before covid
and so i went
c c and so more of that came in then
cove it happened this really seems like
when products figure out that they have
like a male
forgive me i want shark tank sometimes
they have a male skewing pro product
right and they're always like
make the female version right and you're
like you guys have this folder marked
comedy and this folder marked drama yeah
and you're dragging the michael gorman
headshot just to the comedy folder you
don't even have to walk it down the hall
you also lose nothing except sending
somebody out on drums exactly exactly i
i guess maybe should i be telling them
to send me out yeah yeah yeah that's
what you have that's what you kind of
think you're like
god do i broach this subject but yeah i
kind of had to and then for you so fast
forward through covid and and would you
it was your lady at the friend friend at
the time a actor as well no no uh worked
in the business but not no that's not in
front of the camera okay um
uh for some reason that added nuance to
the story to me to be like and we're
both actors we're both hitting in the
bottom
we need help we're both frustrated we're
drinking in the morning we're drinking
in the morning we're drinking in the
evening and pizza at supper time when
you put pizza on a bagel you can have
pizza anytime pizza bites yeah
pizza bagels uh is that a sponsor yeah
i'm sorry i have to do this
pizza in the morning pizza and lemon
juice one second pizza it's harder time
when pizza's on a bagel can have pizza
anytime
yeah
you can have pizza pizza any time
you can have pizza at any time
we got there you got real good by the
end you did like
you just gotta bend the nose sometimes
you just gotta bend the nose like a joe
perry arrows
you moved
you moved it
that was digital manipulation yeah yeah
uh okay sorry yes dot weird uh for 50
added to your uh checkout price
yeah so in november i was kind of like
that the true lies thing came across and
i was like i'm never going to get this
but i'll put myself on tape for it and
because it's an hour long and it just
didn't seem right
because it was too serious
it read serious but later they were like
because what i just i did
improv uh improv stuff in there to make
it funnier yeah because that's what i do
and then
that's what kind of got me the gig
because they were like it's not like an
ncis it's a it's an action comedy we
want the humor in it so all i remember
from true lies was that it was funny it
was funny right and so they want to try
and capture the tone of that and so yeah
um but it didn't read like that it read
you know
if jimmy cameron
you know who's available for script
writing i would have loved to adapt true
lights into an hour long yeah
well when i saw this when i saw it i was
like
of course yeah what a great idea yeah
like of course this should be a show yep
and i'm
ah
is his daughter named dana uh yes i
believe so yeah it's my first
schwarzenegger was just yelling dana
diana
you always bring
like i'm serving like just kind of
heated up chicken broth and then you're
always like is there celery i always i
think i revert to like i always loved uh
daryl hammond's arnold because he would
do the thing that arnold does like in
interviews so he'd be like
we went on vacation and we're talking
about this and that and all this stuff
and all these things and then we we
climbed
the mountain and we get to the top and
we're looking out at all these things
and all this stuff and like these little
nuanced like things that he puts in the
middle of his phrases
and so i kind of stole that from him
i've talked about it on the pod before
but it's one of the best things you can
ever watch is his uh dvd commentary on
total recall where no one told poor
arnold what a dvd commentary was they
were kind of new
and he's just going and this is the
scene where i have to put a locator in
my nose and of course it doesn't fit so
it's very painful to pull it out and
everyone's like no no no like talk about
talk about like what it was like on set
or whatever don't just say and now sean
stone she's an agent and she's fighting
me and i'm going to win but like it
looks like i might lose look i'm going
to say my look it's just like right here
i might lose but then i don't lose
and i flip her over the table i flip
over the table that was something they
only did in the 90s where it was like a
fight scene but it was kind of like is
this sexy yeah you're kind of like i
think i think i saw a nipple like an
apple was in the part of it i like this
one why do i like this
which is idiot man i like this
violence
what fun bill hader i'm like telling
bill hander's story like i know him but
he has a funny story i think he was like
a pa on the movie like erasure
and
he said that at one point arnold was
relaying a story that from the shooting
predator oh wow and he's and arnold is
making schnitzel laying on a grill and
he goes in the jungle i guess so yeah
and then someone came on the side of a
racer or no he's telling the story on
eraser but he's
talking about predator and he's talking
about how he's grilling on the set of
predator and he goes
and and this is how bill aider does he
just goes
bill duke loved the schnitzel
and jesse ventura loved the schnitzel
the car weathers loved the schnitzel
it's just like
that just listing
that's what i mean they're sort of like
a child not childish just a child like
and it's part of why he was good in
kindergarten cop and yes is there
something earnest and just sort of like
and everybody likes jujubes yeah you
pull them out it doesn't have to be at
the movies you put them in your living
room
everybody puts them you get them stuck
in your teeth enjoy later enjoy it later
in the car when you're in the car you
just pick it you pick it out of your
teeth bothering you you look at it
because you want to know what color it
is it's like a booger it's like a booger
but it's okay
nobody mine it could be red it could be
yellow it could be green
it doesn't have to be the one color
maybe it's a bunch of them stuck
together
my mine is getting worse as yours is
good i feel like mine's getting worse no
it's because you're listening to mine
my first was actually from predator
which was kill me i'm here kill me now
kill me now what are you waiting for
it's see it's getting worse
this is perfect because
obviously i was excited to do
impressions with you today and i was
like i hope my pitch is on
and it's off it's i feel like it's fine
well that's because you're a good and
true friend
uh but that's because you're a good and
true friend and you're a liar and you're
lying to me like a true friend might
uh you were saying you booked true lies
uh yeah so it was it was kind of a
rigorous casting but i did end up
booking it and and it was tell me about
the improv process do you remember
because people are interested believe it
or not you and i are walking around
smoking filterless camel cigarettes
riding on longboard skateboards down
hollywood boulevard between casinos
between casinos spitting on the names of
our foes yes you know yes on the stars
but there's a lot of people watching
that are like i want to be an actor i'm
interested in acting and one of the
things that's interesting to me about
funny folk is uh when you add to the
audition in an appropriate way right and
can you think of a line or a moment that
you think there is there was a scene
that we did where so uh my partner in
the show
who's played by uh erica hernandez who's
wonderful
um
the character's name is maria and we
have this sort of contentious
relationship we butt heads a lot and
the scene in the audition was kind of
like this argument that we're having
and
she says something at the very end of
the scene and i think i think for like
dramatic stuff if i were to do this it's
always like at the tail end you just
like button it with something rather
than like pop it in the middle this is
what i'm saying yeah most people have to
audit a class at nyu where like some
actors coming in to give a guest like i
mean it like we're living in a really
good time if you're trying to get into
like a yeah off the path profession
because what you're saying is what we're
saying is when you're auditioning you
don't want to [__] up the whole scene
and add all of this [__] you don't want
to like make it too busy but at the end
great moment
yeah you just so that she says this
thing and then i kind of like i'm i'm
like embarrassed
and then i kind of like cause the the
scene has the tom arnold character gibb
in it he's not in he doesn't have
dialogue but he's there
and so i just kind of turned and was
like um
let's say uh
it's a good-looking sandwich kid where'd
you get that would you get that sandwich
or something like that but it was just
like a like it's like i don't want to be
in this conversation anymore i want to
you know so it was like this little
funny moment and yeah it's just it
doesn't
that that some of those things don't
work to pop something in the middle and
make it about you
it works at the end when you serve
whatever the thing you show them that
you can do it photo real life yeah yeah
and then you get impressions yes yeah
there was another the other one was
the same thing we're having like a back
and forth and then she walks off and i
just went
or like i made some face like
i made some face like
that's you
like you know and like that's you so
yeah
buddy i i think that's fantastic i'm
also interested sorry to keep bringing
this back up like i'm trying to get you
to cry or something but like
in the lifestyle of being a comedian and
an actor and looking for these breaks
which i'm sorry yeah i'm not just saying
this i'm going to watch true lies if
only just for you but i would also
probably be interested in that anyway
yeah so i'm gonna check that out and i
love that you booked perry mason but a
little bit
because when people are talking about
wanting to be an actor i think they're
just like they think they're gonna like
glide on one roller skate topless into
hollywood and have someone start taking
pictures of them and next thing you know
that's certainly what i thought
certainly what both of us did
in the first half yeah our careers yeah
yeah but little you know you should have
put a roller skater on that other foot
yeah because it's a long ride baby two
or better one back two or better but
that that dry spell is interesting to me
you're going well and then and then how
did you
make it work
well i
you know and this is like this is a
cop-out because it's like you know
what's the secret well my secret was i
sold a pilot script
yeah okay and then floated on that
through because it's a great secret
uh it sounds like not a secret like
you're like well i did this other thing
that might not be relatable but i think
it should be relatable because
especially when you're trying to make it
in show business it seems like
diversifying is always really really
good yeah advice i i
you know the old model of the triple
threat is kind of dead people don't sing
and dance and act anymore right i think
imagine there was a time when you guys
like us would have been expected to know
how to dance yeah like would go into
auditions would be
yeah let's see your moves periwinkle and
you're like
right away sir
yeah max what is a mullany says that he
took
tap lessons like as a kid because he was
watching all these old movies and he's
like that's just what you do to get in
show business
this voice
get me sign me up for classes and i'm
going to talk like these boys tap
dancing lessons i took tap i wanted to
do it
and i'm murdered
nuts
spelt with an o instead of a dead
murdered give me a toothpick and two
regular two chocolate donuts give me the
same thing to go
[Laughter]
but yeah like that was but i think now
the the you know
the the other threats are more like
writing and you know directing or
whatever right or whatever like you
can't
i don't know i for me like it just
wasn't working to do one yeah no um who
does it work for i mean uh jason siegel
did this pod and i i really admire him
for doing exactly what i did i probably
i think i learned it directly from him
right which is like
guys especially like us like comedian
guys not your tea cruises right cruz is
rollerblade into town on one roller
blade yes he managed to make that work
i'm not saying it's really just a tiny
skateboard if you think about it a
rollerblade or not a roller blade a
roller skate
[Laughter]
oh my god it's a foot board yeah cause
you could you would be pedaling with the
other foot if you're just wearing one
if you wear one roller skate brother
you're wearing a skateboard you're
wearing a little skateboard
[Laughter]
and you kind of daintily put it up on
your foot
and then go back
fan [__] testing just cruising
speaking well what i was going to say
was i even if you're beautiful i do
think in this town it is a cliche that
there's like 300 000
people yeah there are even people that
kind of look like t croods oh sure tig
notaro
does she look like tom cruise she has a
joke about how she looks like tom cruise
so that joke is tig approved uh but what
i'm saying is i i i i i don't know i've
been overhearing people in my life
lately being like t cruz sucks and i'm
like chris is fantastic he's great you
can't thank you everybody that knows
knows and and i you know i guess i'm one
of these people that has decided to
just
set aside the fact that he probably
knows where shelley miscavige is buried
um
but i go i pay to see his movies
[Laughter]
i will i am
i don't that we should have this year
there's always a moment in the pod where
i'm like not sure how to respond i'm
like
yeah i just
you know we've kind of put away we've
kind of put to the side the scientology
thing
yes where but look i'll be first online
to see that new mission impossible
are you [__]
karate kicking me right now
yeah
i'll be i think i've seen that trailer
no less than a hundred times i just keep
watching it the no doors trailer
i have one note for the trailer they
they go back to that car with no doors a
few too many times okay i've seen a jeep
cherokee true you've seen a carlos door
yeah but but i'm also watching it and
i'm like they [__] did it they always
do it in those movies where i'm like i
don't think i've ever seen
that place
like they find some city yes it's like
have you heard of istanbul yeah 30
clicks south yeah yeah
there's a town called yamashita 30
clicks south there's a little bridge
where we're gonna have issai morales
[Music]
fight with a sword
and you watch it and you it i actually
think those movies
subconsciously make you just go like
the world is big
sometimes thinking that the world is big
like when they're all these ugly pockets
of the world like arguably we sometimes
live in one of like there's certain
parts of l.a where you're like oh god it
just kind of depresses you that it's so
shitty then you watch a movie like that
and you're just like some places the
water is clean
and there's fish you get bluer than my
water
[Laughter]
maybe we are okay
you pick up a fish with your bare hand
and just take a bite yeah just take a
bite out just bite the head off
dunk it right back in the water and it
just bleeds out it's just horrible and
as he continues to walk towards camera
majestic and glistening in this idyllic
place you can still kind of see the fish
bleeding out yeah and blood running down
his chin just a little
um
i'm asking
you so you sold a pilot
yeah i sold a pilot like right as things
kind of locked down tell me the name of
the pilot and i'll tell you what it's
about oh uh it was called the man from
los angeles
all right the man from los angeles this
is a show it's a half hour
single cam comedy yes about a sci-fi
comedy i'll give you that don't correct
me
you're right i'm sorry the man from los
angeles okay now i know it's a science
fiction [__]
okay and it's in the future and it's a
guy aliens come and he's from los
angeles and he only knows movies that's
all
you ruined close really no
oh my god meaning he thinks reality is
movies
and uh they take him and he tells them
all about movies and that's what they
think earth is i like that that's almost
like a like a galaxy quest kind of thing
a galaxy quest being there yeah
all he knows is show business so he's
the man from last night yeah okay i'm
gonna refine it okay aliens abduct one
guy
uh and they happen to get a guy from los
angeles right so they can learn about
what earth is and from this like parody
you learn that like all he knows is what
he knows from like instagram and movies
yes yeah so they get a very skewed
version of the world but they're so
impressed but they're so when they try
to replicate these
oh and then they take it back to their
plan yeah of course and they have like
gifting suites and swag bags and teslas
yeah and they're like this is earth
culture yes you're one of the most
successful cultures yeah this is the met
gala yeah yeah that's right vanity fair
is an essential publication
they just start saying the things he
does
yeah it was uh the it was
it was um
loosely based on an urban legend called
the man from torred and the the pilot
was about a guy who's on a business trip
in new york and when he flies back home
to l.a and he lands
he's in an alternate universe
where his best friend's married to his
girlfriend and you know he's has a
different job and he's got a sort of
he has to
throw himself into this alternate life
while he
also tries to figure out how to get home
yeah last time i fly jet blue i'll tell
you that right now
[Laughter]
i'll tell you this that pilot would be
very short i walk in best friend stop
with my girlfriend
i murder him i don't know what's worse
the alternate universe or those peanuts
where they get those things and why is
the bag so small it's a six hour flight
there's three peanuts in there i need
protein
that's a great idea it was fun is that
an urban legend or just like a myth that
just sounds like a fairy tale it was
it's like a story that's out there yeah
um
about on the streets yeah
the story is that in like it's like 1954
a guy lands in japan and the same thing
kind of happened to him and then but you
know dip so they detain him
and they put him in a hotel and then the
next day they go and he's gone
that's allegedly a true story right
that's what they say right yeah
so i kind of i kind of poached a little
bit of that and then made it my own um
and what and what happened it was hour
long
it no it was a half hour comedy uh it
was at a a streamer and they uh
they
i guess i can just say it it was at hbo
max and when i went in with it they were
like this is this is exactly what we
want this is like a world building show
that's big and has a lot of characters
and stuff and then by the time it went
through development as you know it was
like a long
process it's a pain in the ass by the
time it went through and they said no it
was like
uh you know what we're actually gonna
reboot sex in the city and rerun big
bang theory instead you know they were
they were they just changed their model
completely oh wow and uh and so it was
not it was no longer about these big
world buildings just because they were
coming off game of thrones and i think
they went world yeah exactly
so you know and that's fine but that
happens
yeah and that always happens and uh
you're talking to a fellow who's just
canceled because they were like we're
going a completely different way well
this is what the best way to get
canceled actually you don't want to be
canceled because you're like yeah stink
is that what that that was the thing
maybe i'm believing what i was told but
it seems real is that they cancelled
like four of their comedies and they're
like we're doing drama
like that i wonder if they cancelled
your show so they could put mine on
actually i mean i'm supposed to be like
you son of a [__] you [__] my wife
i would be
thrilled if that were the case
because at least it'll be i mean not at
least i mean i'd love it to be a friend
and so right right just gonna be with
somebody
i'm glad it's you i'm drunk
i'm glad cbs is with you baby i i wanted
to ask you about that because i had i
i watched every episode of that show you
did i did
and i was i'm curious because
again like
we didn't know each other then but i
know we came up at the same time and you
know when when we were starting out
it was like the advent of like alt
comedy rafi and all that stuff i ended
up doing more stuff for like the pit and
that but yeah um
and i'm just curious a little bit
at the pet i just ended up doing a lot
of stuff at the pit
and uh and enough
and i was curious to know because so my
thing is
when i was in my
late 20s early 30s i'm like chasing snl
um i want to do this i want to do that i
want to hop around the dream is to get
on like a parks and rec or something
like that which you'd be perfect for by
the way you're like a true died in the
wool you're like a chris pratt you
should be in jurassic park i should be
in jurassic park i will bring this up i
don't mean the movie i think we should
make a dangerous park
and let you know you should work there
no but like you have like the first
thing i said when you came to the door i
was like you're always better because
the level of funny you are you should
have a hobble you should be hobbled
and you should you should have one
escape
i keep waiting for that like when i'm
talking to you i keep waiting for
something to level it that lets me know
why you developed a personality like i
did mine is boob shadow and sort of like
a spotty ready lithuanian thing
you uh you could be like a crisp rap i
don't know i just want to get it out
there thank you thank you play that clip
for your agent old one folder out of two
at wme well so my my question is is like
so i i was trying for that for such a
long time and then i got to be like 38
and i was like well someone just hand me
a [__] cbs procedure and put me out
of my [__] misery and just let me
laugh for ten years on yeah like an hour
long let me ride it out on bones and
hopefully that's what will now happen
and i'll have some stability for a long
time instead of just hopping around
through guest spots but i was curious
because like i feel like when
in in the in the early 2000s or
mid-2000s when we were starting it
wasn't cool to do the multi-cam
thing right you know like everybody was
looking to do something
new and different or weird people all
our age were raised with multicam so i
think it might have felt like the old
thing yes exactly so you wanted to be on
um wilford
is that the show wilfred wilfred i had a
pitch meeting at fx one time and the
phone rang i'm sitting on a couch like
this and the phone rang
next to me and they go just pick it up
and hang it up
and i picked it up and uh and i hung it
up and then i picked it up again and i
go
what they canceled wilfred oh my god
that it did go well in the room
of course it killed uh i think actually
i'm putting this together for the first
time people our age grew up with multi
camps and that was what comedy was
called and friends being the tail end of
that right then arrested development
comes out when we're like 20 20 20
ish around there yeah so in our 20s yeah
and we're like oh this is the new thing
this is what you want to be on a show
that looks like a movie right uh they
were doing different things so then i
think that built that stigma also it's
just it is kind of traditionally a
different joke style
i was writing a multi-cam pilot and i
was like i just kind of like it because
you can make
i'm not saying
let's put it this way
single cam you're just making a lot more
like subtle
sort of real grounded moments yeah and
in multicam you're free to be like
okay i guess that's a no yeah like it's
like that
wow
and that's fun yeah i was thinking i
didn't but it's this close to be like
like a burp and someone being like i'll
take that as a no like that sort of
thing
but there is a a music to it i'm not
saying you can't elevate it and do it in
a really interesting way but there's
something liberating like improv comedy
where you're like if there's a joke take
it yeah do it don't don't necessarily
just yeah play it for just realism let's
go see a play today right okay right so
go on right no that was that's what i
was curious about was like
i don't think you're the kind of person
that would ever do anything because you
felt that you had to but
you know
notoriously for those who don't know
like the multicam thing the schedules
are better now you have a family like
did it did it fit better for you now
i've just been i've been spending the
past like three first of all generous
question thank you i've been spending
like when the show was canceled i was
like totally fine i was like oh yeah
okay that's not personal mark gross the
guy who created it my friend he called
me let me know i was like oh that's a
bummer right
but you know we immediately started
looking for the upside we're like but at
least we know
right we had been waiting for a while
we're like at least we have our answer
right we can move on and you know we did
a good job and we're proud of it
at least they aired them all sometimes
they cancel it like two in yep and it's
over
and i think i'm not sure how that works
but i'm pretty sure you only get paid
for whatever your guarantee was not to
be
coarse but i think the ones that you
didn't shoot or didn't air i mean that
that just never happened right so it
goes away um so i was like at least they
aired them all we're proud of it all
this positive stuff and then like slowly
but surely exactly what you're saying
started creeping in where i was like i
miss my friends i me i made friends with
all of these people sure
um especially katie lowe's we got really
close my my tv wife
and the schedule was so good
and so fun
and when i say easy i don't mean it
didn't have its challenges because it
was just challenging enough to be
interesting
but it wasn't so hard that you were
pulling your hair out right but it was
the schedule and the lifestyle was so
good that it was uh impossible to find
other people other actors comedians that
you could talk to about it right because
nobody wanted to hear it yes it would be
like you're
like me
flying to saint louis and and your
all the [__] that goes into that yeah
and you're like i drive ten minutes and
i go in my parking spot and you walk on
set and flick a little cigarette okay
and like
you [__] like if you could see
what a monday looked like which is where
the script is the roughest
you do a table read and then later on
you're kind of rehearsing it right but
you know they're going to change it it's
mostly so you're on the set you're in
the kitchen with the swinging door and
you're sitting in the chairs at the
kitchen table with these friends and
every script and the director's there
and you're just
you talk and [__] around and laugh
for like 30 minutes and then you
rehearse for 15 minutes and you're like
this is all gonna change but maybe maybe
go to the kitchen go to the fridge when
you say that right let's try it you do
it once or twice you're done
early afternoon
i'll say
i pick my daughter up every day oh
that's great but that when to your point
in the coolness thing
uh it
because when the when the offer came in
i was like this isn't like cool it's not
like the cover of rolling stone nobody's
going to be like how we're all on on
spin
[Laughter]
just like i'm on a bowling ball though
how pete holmes bowled over america
and then it says curly sue reboot in the
works like underneath it for some reason
like it's not that
and i
i've told this story before but i called
all of so many of my showbiz friends and
asked them their advice and everybody
was like what what the [__] are you
doing but i grew up in that i came up in
that rafifi way where it was it like if
eugene murman didn't think it was cool
you shouldn't do it right and then i'm
so glad i did it and to your point
uh i would do it
again and val said to me just the other
day she was like look you did a good job
you weren't an [__] and i've heard uh
a lot of stories about people on
multicam's kind of having meltdowns sure
because you're the fancy boy on set and
you kind of start to believe your own
hype and turn into a dick no one was a
dick on that set we were all nice we had
a great time we did our job we were
funny we were on time we we had a good
time uh she's like i wouldn't be
surprised if you got another right
network multicam or network show and i
was like
any day yeah i've completely flipped i
don't have a lot of people that give
this advice but i'm like if if a network
calls with a show
do it yeah don't just do it because
everybody goes must be nice make a lot
of cheddar cheese i'm like
buddy cheddar cheese i get it it's fine
i need cheddar cheese
a good idea actually pay me in money not
cheese this time payment gruyere why is
money always like
fruit cheese lettuce great some good
bread for that do you just want a salad
making your bread and butter look i need
a job i need to make some uh bread i
need to make some bread and butter i
need to make some cheese i need to make
some lettuce a little bit of green i
think you just want a sandwich
and then we widen a reveal there in a
subway you're gonna love this job
you get nine employee subs a day but i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell you something we
don't recommend you take all night
you have to take all nine
what
good news bad news you get nine they
watch you eat them bad news jared comes
by this is in the 90s yeah yeah pre-scan
jared comes by this is pre-scanned he
says that this is pre-scandal what oh we
knew the whole time
yikes
um so yes i
the thought of doing something
that you like this is what you tell me
the goal of my life now and it seems
insane and the majority of the world's
cultures would not understand what i'm
about to say but i'm 43
through history i mean
i'm 43 years old and just now i'm
starting to be like
what would be the best
life
not just like
what will make michael gorman look at me
and go gee whiz
what would make nick crawl again me and
be like how do you do laughs
i'm having the same thing i'm just like
form 42.
relatively the same a job a job
this is what maddie and i would say to
be a worker among workers just to have a
place
to do your thing to do it well
to not be uh not very 43 not be
traveling around not be chasing it not
be like
grinding and hustling like i really feel
like
there's still some grind in me and still
some hustle in me for sure but like the
young man's thing of like do you want to
go to indiana to do a 3 p.m show in a
firehouse for 28 mormons i'm like
what's yes i mean what's it pay yes i
mean [__] i'm already committed yeah
like it pays a tiny bag of jet bloopers
yeah i yeah if someone told me uh they
wanted to fly me out to uh sonoma now
yeah to do trump at the yellowtail you
know yeah [__] retreat yes which i
did several times like no i don't think
at this point the days are over i'm true
lies baby but i'll tell you this and
this is kind of interesting so i i hope
for you i called mike barbiglia and
after the show was going i was like you
know it's interesting
uh
i'm not working on a lot of my ideas
anymore like i kind of thought
like it satiated every need
there's a great line in mad men where
roger sterling says when this job is
good it meets every need and how we roll
met every need it meant my social need
it's great it meant my comedy need like
my performance i gotta razzle dazzle
them yeah yeah but all like the number
one really was the social
feeling like you belonged and that you
were making something with 150 200 other
people right right like literally the
builders and the likes yeah yeah yeah so
i just felt about so satisfied yeah and
i was also we were all so good
financially so i was like i just don't
feel the need to come home and work on
that movie script and mike burbigly was
like that's one of the reasons i don't
do shows like that like i think
berbiglia gets offered things like that
right i think he says no
and the reason is is like
there's a certain thing of like
have you seen the movie big fish yeah
you know when he he's in the middle of
his journey and he goes into spectre the
perfect town yes that's where steve
buscemi lives
and they're all like stay stay inside
yeah yeah stay inspected and he has to
leave right he has to eventually escape
right uh
there is the honeypot trap
as i'm saying this
buddy please put me back in the honeypot
yeah
but there are like those andy warhol
ride or die artists like rabiglia that
are like there's a risk to doing
something
that dies you and actually
satiates your needs right it might be
you don't write
the man from los angeles you know right
like right
but like really consider that like if
you're
a hovering awareness looking at your
life at the end of it
and and they're like and that's when you
book true lies and you're like i
remember that that was the best day of
my life and they're like actually look
what would have happened if you hadn't
booked through live and they smear and
it's like you create the covert cure you
know like something like that i'm not of
course i'm exaggerating but there's like
i think you and i are saying the same
thing like yeah
that's okay we've put enough of the
grind in
because when we were young all we did
was grind and there's a little bit of a
shift in priorities yes and i feel like
because i'm i'm i was curious about that
because yeah i'm having the same thing
it's like now i'm now i'm going into a
thing where i'm doing like an hour long
show which has a little more
drama to it there's a comedy element to
it but it's the stakes are going to be
higher actually after these notes i'm
laying out yes
but it's like not the thing i intended
yeah but i'm super excited about it and
i love it i'm going to tell you
something everything we're saying is
just speculative speculative it's just
to give us not give us something to talk
about but it's looking at the other side
for fun well maybe you would have
written
you know
steel magnolias oh but i could have done
that but mike this is kind of the bigger
point and this is my current fascination
i'm like
when better life when better life right
when right like like i really think
especially in western consumer achiever
society
i see it honestly with people in my
family like older people in my family
i'm like
oh you'll just never do it because by
the time you could retire or slow down
the grooves in your brain to work earn
your approval like you're only good if
you're being extra shiny and killing it
and in the trades and in the mix and all
that stuff those grooves are so
in there that i'm like
pick your pick your person meaning i
don't mean to single out tim allen but
tim allen would love to be back in the
mix and can you can you blame him but
like
should we be
or is it possible to strive for
something else can i just
make my life i know we're talking about
being on a show and having a good life
but like instead of
ride or die and not stopping until you
get the exact thing you wanted or doing
this thing that's just a wonderful life
right yeah yeah and i and i i do think
at 42 i'm settling into that mindset of
like
you know
i was i was pretty bummed when i didn't
get snl because that was like a dream
for a long time you auditioned oh yeah
tell me the store
um i auditioned in 2011
[Music]
and
i had just
i had like just signed with
with uh my agency and they were like
what do you want to do and i was like
well i want to i want to audition for
snl it had been a dream of mine for a
long time and i was like do impressions
and what if they were like snl
like that's when you realize they don't
know you at all
saturday night live saturday night live
saturday night live are you planning a
meeting right now you want to see me on
saturday night
this was maybe a mistake
what if i was like what if i was like i
auditioned in 2011 and i got it and i
was uh on the cast for seven years and
they never used me
[Laughter]
we're not really sure what to do with
they didn't you put me in the credits
but i was paid please don't go out for
good night
i tried
i just what
tell me who else was auditioning when
you were there
i don't remember the first time uh the
second time was in 2013 and it was
right when they had that mass exodus it
was like
uh
armisen and sedakis and hader they all
left
and uh
so they were basically seeing everyone
and i remember i think the the when the
new cast came in was like beck bennett
kyle mooney
uh
my buddy john milheiser got on he did a
season
um so it was that that was the
season i was auditioning for um
but yeah it was just it was sort of
run-of-the-mill audition yeah um who did
you do
who did i do i did andre i think
oh
gosh i don't remember even
i might have done bail
i hope he did at the time at the time i
was trying to do a will our net
i haven't done that in a long time
i can't do it i can hear it
yeah he's just got this low sort of you
know
low low smoker's voice
[Laughter]
uh josh rubin
and i he he lets me do
his jason bateman which is just oh
hey
uh yeah um
don't do that buddy or something but
it's just the uh is all i want to do
i've never i've never done this
for him because i'm friendly with him
but i i would i was i forget when i was
doing this i think i was just doing it
on a facetime with a friend but it was
like
uh a scene from horrible bosses three
and i don't do the other impressions
well but
i
got to do like a sedace from hanging
around
and
so it's like charlie day would be like
yeah we need to do something cool like
blow up a bank
uh
oh that's like that's like not a bad
idea we'll blow up a bank and then and
then bait would be like guys guys
we're not uh
we're not gonna blow up a bank
that
was great
we got to do something cool like blow up
a bigger blow up a bank
my sedatives is always
wait
milkshakes
i can't even do it i'm off my head
he has a thing where he kind of thinks
out loud yeah so like he'll have a
thought that's not totally
done yet but he just so he's he was like
oh you know it's like
he kind of um you know he can't he like
he's not he's not done formulating it
yet but he's thinking about it out loud
yes and so he has these little
mannerisms that i've picked up and then
ted lasso is just that with the southern
accent i believe
yeah it's just it's like it's yeah
kansas or something yeah yeah yeah love
it need it um love that where were we we
were just in the brink of
i was oh yeah
oh yeah yeah you did and you did i did i
also did um this was like a karaoke
thing that i do
is uh what do you mean a bit you did
when you'd play do gary sing karaoke i
will do um
uh what's the uh hey jealousy but as
dracula tell me do you think it'd be all
right if i could just crash here tonight
so i did that and then when i came off
stage
one of the crew guys came up to me he
goes you know our stage manager is
married to the lead singer at jyn
blossoms and i was like no i was like i
did not know that but she's like she
loved it
i was like okay
wow
hey jealousy yeah
hey jealousy
and i do like oh i forget i can't think
of all the lyrics but you inject like
uh like you know
tell me do you think it'd be all right
to suck your blood tonight like just
adding in little draculisms
i love that yeah my only karaoke bit is
usually we'll go to a korean place and
there's videos that have nothing to do
yes oh i love that with the uh song yeah
and i'll just sing what i'm seeing so
i'll be like that's a great and i'm in
the cab and i'm with a girl and it looks
like we just maybe broke up oh now we're
kissing and like it usually does i like
to do um
uh what a wonderful world and what i'll
do is i'll start it
like you know uh i see trees a green
louis clouds of right
and i do a duet with myself basically
as louis armstrong and myself and i just
toss it back and forth that was one of
my
it might be the earliest impression i
ever did because when we were in like
third grade yeah me and my brother would
go nothing to myself
there's a frog in my throat we thought
that was so funny that he just needed to
cough
i recently thought of a bit i don't know
where to put it but like
louis armstrong and jimmy durante having
a conversation with each other because
it's just the same voice oh okay he
he
he's just that you know he he's a little
sharper and like but it's like
alright jimmy
hey
you like
they basically have the same voice so
you really can't discern who's talking
when oh no
i want to know who the first person was
to play that song what a wonderful world
over like dystopian footage
because that's been
overdone so many times it's like just
show the worst stuff and be like yeah
louder white
they're really saying
i love you like the a bomb
yes you're like oh god okay here we go
again give to unicef all right
all right sarah mclaughlin you got me
same with sarah glock i used to love
angel
loved angel
now i just see a chihuahua being like
please yeah please help it's got one eye
yeah it rolls out
several fish in the background
so you didn't get it what happened in
is there any story
if i remember correctly it was i believe
that was the year that kate mckinnon got
hired and i think they
they had the audition and then were like
you know what we're just gonna we're
high we need like four women
so we're just hiring women which which
happens for those of you who don't know
that happens a lot with that show where
the you know
you'll audition and then they're like
well we just need
this and this we don't you know we don't
need another white
you know
uh game show host guy yeah you know we
have that or we have you know we need
we're looking for this so
it just it was not
game show guy yeah they always have the
game we already have the game show guy
we have we have the game show guy we
don't need another game show guys we
have the parnell
beck is our parnell
kate is our wig
he's just really phoning it in who's our
will
lauren i think we need a will this year
will was our john
and john was our dan
[Laughter]
oh
those guys were on the same season
acroid yeah okay he's malfunctioned
dennis miller did its own thing but i
never liked it
[Laughter]
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought to us by draftkings
the wait is almost over a new football
season is about to begin get ready for
the nfl week one action with draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl to celebrate the
return of football draftkings is giving
new customers a can't miss offer bet
just five dollars on any football game
and get two 200 in free bets instantly
want more action for opening night
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion get up
seven you win bet on any nfl team of
your choice and if your team leads up
leads by seven points at any point
during the game you get paid instantly
even if your team loses draftkings is
safe secure and reliable best of all you
can deposit and withdraw your cash
whenever you want so download the
draftkings sportsbook app now and use
promo code weird to get 200 in free bets
instantly when you place a 5 bet on any
football game that's code weird only at
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl minimum age
and eligibility real minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply uh see
our show notes for more details back to
the show
have you ever almost died
great question
yes
i uh
i krasinskied
i was at a we were staying at a lake in
michigan
like a small no it's a small lake uh
about 15 minutes away from lake michigan
it's just like it's a hard lake to be
yeah i'm a lake in michigan
lake michigan
about 15 minutes
no
it's like being jim carrell
[Laughter]
and there was this little inlet
and i was
sure that i could swim across it so i
rode i rode a bike around i thought for
example
so i rode my horse
mike no
i got on a bike i rode around to the end
of the lake to the inlet and i was gonna
swim across the inlet to this other side
where there was like a beach
forgive the uh city boy question but an
inlet is so like it's like like picture
like
um the lake is like the mickey mouse's
face yeah and the inlet is like the ear
it's like a smaller like little cove i
see it within the lake i'm really glad i
asked and now i'm thinking about mickey
mouse and it makes me happy
and i'm gonna swim across so i decided
to swim across this little section of
the lake
to this like beach area on the other
side
and um
oh no i didn't ride my bike around that
time i got uh my wife at the time
dropped me off on a jet ski on one side
and i was like i'm gonna swim
and i
nearly made it to the other side but i
got gassed real fast and i i
put my feet down because i thought there
was i thought i could stand and i
couldn't i was still in deep water and
i'm watching her right away and she
turns
and i'm waving i'm like waving like i'm
[__] drowning and she just goes
waves waves and then turns and goes back
to the house and i basically was like
all right i took a deep breath and i
went underwater and swam the rest of the
way until i could touch bottom
and then i could stand but i it was
really scary for like
a good minute i was like i cannot hold i
cannot tread water anymore
okay
so that was the closest to death that
the way that we say hello everything's
fine the same hand gesture is i'm dying
i'm drowning i'm drowning in front of
you i'm drowning and you can help yeah
you're on a motorcycle of the sea yes
come get me easily yeah won't even be
five minutes of your day yeah and she's
like
yep
see ya i'm gonna go have a sandwich
nightmare yeah it was it was off as i
watched her drive off i was just like
i'm on my own and you
and you went down
to make it easier to swim yes i just i
just couldn't stay above anymore so you
were wasting too much energy staying
above yeah so i went under and i just
thank god yeah what a nutshell you have
a poopy your pants
or when's the last time you pooped your
pants uh the last time i pooped my pants
was uh intelligence christian
[Laughter]
the last the last time i pooped my pants
um it was
it would would have been in like
2009 or 10
i had the flu
and i'm laying on the couch with like
102 fever 102 flu poo some 102
which sounds like a children's show and
you trusted a fart i trusted a fart too
too loudly and i and i just yeah
what did i just i was just watching
something and he said
he said you know i'm stealing this now
but yeah i stood up and i felt the fart
run down my leg
[Laughter]
is there another it seems like you have
a bunch of poo story uh poop your pants
stories no
no no no i really do
is that i like that that's like a method
you use for your guests where it's like
it sounds like you do and they go
all right the other one is
only because he went well the last time
i just met like you know since being
like a child yeah yeah i don't know
no i have not pooped my pants uh
i think that was the only adult time
other than the underwater 69
um what about the meaning of life we're
at that point in the show oh christ
uh
did you were you raised religioso i was
raised in a very strict irish catholic
house i went to catholic school my
entire life
was it grades first through twelve was
it everything everybody sees in the
movies
it was uh
they had they had done away with the
beatings by the time i got there
good uh but but the um
the psychological
beatings were still very much in play
really yeah for sure and did you have to
do all that like what are the mortal
sins michael yeah you know they take you
to confession and all this [__] you go
to mass uh
i think we had mass was the first
wednesday of every month you'd go to
class mass
and all that stuff and we went to church
every sunday
um i was just so i one of the guys i
love uh very much he's like a father to
me is rich roar he's a franciscan
uh which is so that's catholic and he
was talking about how like
spirituality is almost all about
uh self-surrender realizing that your
ego isn't [__] and letting it die and
waking up to your true identity so he
goes
so really until you're like
30. like really when you like fully are
ready to start going yeah and that's by
the way when jesus did it yeah you know
what i mean 30 you start to kind of go
like wait a minute yeah this thing i
call pete is really just an abstraction
i'm going to let it go and realize we
can even use scientific language i'm i'm
awareness or i'm consciousness or i'm a
part of something bigger or i it's all
one whatever you want to sure
but the peep thing is really just kind
of like my outfit
yes but that sure that self-surrender
can't really happen until as ramdas
would say his picture's up there you
have to be somebody before you can be
nobody when spirituality is sort of
about becoming nobody so anyway
richard a catholic was like until
they're that age all we should be doing
is praising them and supporting them
right he's like just being like you're
good i see you because they need to get
all that competition out of their way
all of that energy all of that zeal for
life they're new you're new here yeah
you want to touch and run and throw and
all that stuff so like it's all that
first stuff is just about giving them a
good container but like it's crazy i'm
not saying it's crazy i think it might
be a little misguided to start telling
people
like the serious teachings of mysticism
or religion i can't smoke a cigarette
till i'm 18 but i'm supposed to embody
this life philosophy that is in front of
six years old or five years old which is
which yes i the more i think about it
the more i'm like i really think that's
insane yeah it should just be
this is your group like it's nice to
kind of belong to a group this is how to
be nice even though deep down that's not
what it's about but we're going to teach
you how to be nice
uh teach you some basics make you a
little less afraid of death the right
and wrong of it is great yeah
unnecessary yeah and there's a lot i
mean i don't i don't regret growing up
that way i i think it shaped me into a
good person yeah um
but
even even the philosophical thing about
it wasn't even the reason why i stopped
going it was it's more like
if you're fed the same meal the same
dinner every night for 18 years yeah
you're not go and somebody put something
new in front of you you're gonna you're
gonna go for that yeah i'm done with it
i'm done loaves and fishes every night
you get a little you get a little wafer
and a sip of wine yeah and some places
they dip
you gotta ask ahead is this a dip church
do you dunk yeah is this transgressions
or sins
uh when you do the lord's prayer um so
you what when you broke away from your
catholic meal what did you do
i think i completely kind of rejected it
for a long time
no food no food
and although atheism is its own food
absolutely we're taking a break from
religion is its own atheism is probably
just as much effort as
you know sure well keeping up with the
way that any world view is it seems like
it's the i'm out yeah
it's hard you're not off the hook it
would be great if you could just go i'm
out and be off the hook yeah even some
we have friends that just seem so
carefree and they don't give a [__]
about any like why are we here what is
this all about where are we going i
don't buy it
no meaning it's unconscious like you
might just be going
and and watching the new sonic movie
stoned
but somewhere i should have gotten
stoned when i watched it
me too
uh although benny schwartz you were
great uh benchwoods wonderful schwartz
one of my best schwartz he's a ben he's
a schwartz you put him together he's ben
schwartz
but i still think it's at that point
it's latent it's unconscious meaning
your existential dread is still at play
you're just not dealing with it and the
work that you're putting off not to make
not to say everybody needs to do it but
i kind of think you do at a certain
point you have to go like
mike
we're [__] molecules it's nuts yeah
it's a [__]
conundrum and if you think the origin of
these conscious molecules having a
conversation on something that we've
agreed to call a couch if you think
that's nothing that's still a very
interesting world view it's still it
doesn't get you off the hook is my point
right if you think this is a cosmic
accident it doesn't mean like you
understand where it's going or what it
does next yes or anything really yeah
and that that to me is like you know if
you talk to somebody and they're like
you know and you don't necessarily have
to be afraid of it but if somebody's
like i don't you know death i don't
really think about it it's like you
don't yeah
because that's some that that's all i
think about you know or like these heavy
things that you know
you act like doesn't bother you but you
have to think about it you have to
wonder what it's the clock on the game
yeah yeah you can't play the game well
if you don't know what quarter you're in
yeah and what the score is yeah and i
actually that goes back to what i think
christianity is about at its deeper
levels when you are a fully formed
person
is not just acknowledging that death is
coming but that you know to quote
the ancients the greeks yeah we have to
die before we die you have to if you're
afraid of dying you haven't figured out
who you truly are
and that's the work of life is to go
like wait there are these things that
you use as markers to identify yourself
but they're in shift they're in flux
yeah they're changing yeah and i can
change a lot of them the extreme example
i like to use is like even if you're
like i'm from this area or i'm this or
that i could somehow extract your
consciousness like in a science fiction
movie and put it in an amorphous blob
and move that amorphous blob to a planet
that's entirely water and you just swim
with other jellyfish
and you're there for a million years you
won't even remember ever being michael
gorman but you
the the backdrop upon which we write all
of those stories right will still be the
same right that's what spirituality is
it goes okay then what is the backdrop
what is the least
divisible
essence element of existence yeah and
that's who you are yeah and when you can
realize you're that you get a lot less
nervous that you're going to die i think
that the story is going to die or that
the white the white board is going to be
wiped clean right right i think my
grandmother lived to be a hundred
and towards the end she really only
started to like
lose her sort of faculties in the last
six months that she was alive and
towards the end
she kept saying like i'm ready
i'm ready to go and you hear that when
older people
i'm ready to go yeah and i just you know
you can own the best you can probably
hope for is that you reach a point
where you're ready to go when it's time
and it's not a surprise you know that's
another one of those well we talk val
and i i don't know if it's more but we
always go do you want to die happy or do
you want to die sad and i i don't think
i don't know what the right answer is if
you're happy you're flush with this
feeling of like i can't wait to see
what's next i want to extend this i want
like you're excited about that or do you
want to like we decided the last time we
talked about it
you want to have just rounded a mountain
you did a thing
you wrapped season
317 of true lies
and you've gone over the mountain
and you're like that was good like your
grandmother that was good
but you don't want to be like and
tomorrow we shoot season nine it's like
wait yeah
but that's
it's it's a joke but it's also like
the non-attachment
to things is is one of the secrets it
seems not just how to die well but just
how to live well yes to realize that
this conversation is the only thing
that's happening is how to have a good
conversation right but if i was kind of
going like and then i'm going to have a
tuna fish time which
that's dividing me
yeah and and you can let go into
whatever into the mystery or whatever it
is but do you um no wrong answer uh do
you think
consciousness survives the body do you
think uh
death is the end i
i i like to think that
you know consciousness survives that
it's an energy yeah and then it can't be
destroyed um
and i think i you know part of me is
just like
oh maybe that's the science of it and
then part of me is like
well this is the hope that i hold
so that i just don't go crazy thinking
that there's nothing after yeah yeah you
know so
but either way it's you know it's that's
sort of comforting to me to think that
yeah at least
there's some sort of energy that
survives on i completely agree i i mean
obviously i agree everybody knows i'm
pretty woo by this point but val and i
just went to the brea tarpits and we
were watching a thing about the end of
the ice age and what happened to all the
woolly mammoths how they went extinct
and just how cruel
obviously when you look at it as a story
it's very cruel like even the the
tarpons themselves as they go in and and
then another animal would go in to eat
that animal and then the other one was
going to eat that animal and there's
millions of bones in this
one
and you're just like wow that really is
a pretty stark example of a pretty
uncaring universe it's just like
sometimes the universe is dark
and you want to eat this world will will
literally eat you alive right yeah and
you're going like well [__] that that
doesn't really seem to jive with this
idea that like there's purpose and we
survived death and all that stuff but i
was like no it doesn't the cot to me the
awareness that is looking at the eyes of
the mammoth is the same as the awareness
that's looking out our eyes sure and and
yeah they're gone in the same way that
i'll be gone pete will be gone
but i think the the the
that smallest sampling the the most
fundamental thing to both that mammoth
and me
isn't going anywhere and can't go
anywhere right and that that isn't that
that's why it's like good news bad news
it's like good news you never die bad
news
you know mike o'gorman dies
you know what do you mean yes so it's
like both i can't
from where i'm standing and that could
be completely wrong and maybe i'll be
standing somewhere else
it's bad bad new to you to your ego i'll
never be able to be like don't worry
you're still going to be number one
you know well that's i i think about
that too because i think about
i think about the process of that energy
and sort of a reincarnation idea where
um
you know maybe that energy does go into
something else and then well if you come
back like
what if i come back as a [__] dog or
you know someone who needs a wheelchair
or you know yeah like i think like
whereas like
maybe when you're younger you think
well i'll just come reincarnation is
just a human coming back as a human
right yeah but there's a million
different ways there's a million
different things dean matterman had a
great bit about that where he's like the
chances of me being born in america
twice
and he was just like he doesn't want to
live i actually think
scientifically there is a higher chance
than he would think because
if you're buried in the states your
proteins
and stuff are devoured and consumed by
the planet in this in the in america and
then you might come back there and then
you might come back which is why as a
nation we refuse to grow it's the same
it's the same people we die going
mountain
cheese fries
that's why i want to be i don't i don't
know i want to be cremated i would love
to be just not embalmed and just dumped
off a boat in the middle of the ocean
by fish
and just not having to rot in a box
would you like to be buried cremated or
eat by fish
take eat by fish i'll tell you just in
case you get as much out of this image
as i did but rupert spyro who i love
s-p-i-r-a he's incredible
he talks about
he he believes reincarnation is a
possibility but he says that everything
that's happening is made of of
consciousness right okay which sounds
like such a weird idea until you go like
imagine everything's under water
and like i said everything's molecules
and i am a activity of that water
meaning i'm like a little spiral sure in
the water and that exists for a while
and there's a little spiral up but it's
really made and what he means by that is
like my experience just like your
experience is just these sensations that
are experienced in consciousness nothing
happens outside of consciousness right
right we think we're like but we're out
here and consciousness is something we
use to
you know experience an objective reality
he's like there is no objective reality
the only reason we think this exists is
because when i do this something is
written on consciousness that i that i
go it's this shape and it's just right
gives the perception of concept like in
the way that a movement of water gives
the perception of a little tornado under
the water and he thinks if that stops
obviously nothing's happened to water
the tornado or the what is it called
underwater um uh
whirlpool whirlpool works no katie's
squirrel
we're all stoned right now wait not a
squirrel well a bugle
on a bugle it's a bugle of water
but then he goes once that's dissipated
nothing
water spout
did you go to waterspout.com
she said no
um but it does
that's what i thought
that makes sense
whirlpool okay it sounds like that
should be like a
like i picture that as like a tornado
where the top is on the surface yeah
like a
that's a water spout okay according to
waterspout.com right
so anyway
everything that dissipates is still
there and then if it's if it runs into
another current of movement it would
that same
all the same bits of water would be
reanimated right that's a way of like
visualizing what could be happening at a
moment like death sure
i don't know just damage or like same
i always think about like uh i was
fascinated by black holes and how like
time slows down when you
reach the event horizon yeah scary movie
i don't i don't care for it um
i don't even know that's like out of my
pay grade so you're going towards a
black hole in time slower yeah time
slows down the closer you get into it
how do they know that they send a little
uh alarm clock like an 80s alarm clock
they're like look it's slowing down
so much of science my watch is ahead of
the clock that we send into the event
horizon of this black hole that's good
science jimmy they tied a string to an
alarm clock and then they just sent it
out and then they pulled it back they
pull it back and they go yeah time then
group watch is ahead of this
time could it just be the hands of the
clock no it was time itself
[Laughter]
because i don't even know how you
measure time
now we are just two stoners objectively
like isn't
time
like does does time exist i it only i
mean it does only because well i feel
like
we could say anything we could just have
we could we don't have to have hours and
minutes we could just have one 24-hour
unit of time yes but we've broken it up
because of things this size
yeah
and we know things are decaying at a
rate that is observable right
and i really think it has a lot to do
with our heartbeats gave us this sense
of like sure rhythm and then this than
this and this
but really
sorry to freak everybody the [__] out
including me
uh this now is the same now how many
this is also rupert spyro how many nows
have you experienced i mean
uncountable
right or just one or just one yeah just
one long right right i i know you mean
it seems like frames of a movie that
really was all just like
it's it was the same one yeah yes oh man
my edible just kicked in it was a jujube
you pick it out of your neck out of your
necks
sometimes it gets stuck in your teeth
you just you're in the car and your
tongue finds it and you just pick it out
of your teeth
trying to remember who else before we
close let's let's not forget any
impressions that is so hot today
it is hot
real hot
but this is the sleepy summer series
this happens every summer the episodes
just get a little more chill do we know
how hot it is today
oh but a wet 77 oh it's humid
uh i'm trying to remember the old wet
77.
everybody knows i drove that thing
around for years
[Laughter]
what i'm trying to remember what
impressions
you do that maybe are more rare or
you're more proud of i've been doing
this one at home are you watching this
show the offer
the offer it's a mini series on i think
it's on paramount plus it's a
mini-series about the making of the
godfather
so it's
actors playing the producers and people
who put together the movie
and matthew goode who's a british actor
that i quite like
he is playing uh legendary mega producer
robert evans
oh yeah he's not doing like a totally
true to life impression but i've been
doing his impression of robert i was
just like around the house from the kid
stays in the picture yes yes and so i'm
i walk around the house and i'm like
you [__] cats seem to need to
eat every [__] day
[Laughter]
and i'm just doing his robert evans like
around the house to no one can i just
say i watched a documentary like a mini
featurette documentary on the making of
butch cassidy on the sundance kid
and there's this brief moment where
they're talking to the director and this
is around the time you know maybe a
little before bob evans but like there
was just a time when men
just talked that way and yeah the guy
was like and of course we got julie
julie's a hot dame she's got perfect
breasts and you're just like yes
it's when you're like my buddy's
watching it and i left like i sent him
like a voice memo i was like so you say
you lost your wallet
well that reminds me of the time my wife
ali mcgraw left me for screen sensation
steve mcqueen
they met on the getaway which ended up
being a fantastic picture
[Laughter]
fantastic so yeah i like that one a lot
um
any that you do that nobody else seems
to do i i mean bill is kind of that bail
is your i know bail is your special
i used to have a i feel like i have a
bunch i just can't think of it um
don't even worry about it i mean andre
is kind of that's a singular one that i
don't i mean a lot of people do like
lines from the princess bride and
kindness will try and sound but i feel
like i now have the fact of the andre
the giant talk show isn't in its 11th
season
well maybe true lies can make that
happen i mean you know catapult me into
a place where i can bring it back i
definitely have thought about doing that
again it was so good it's fun it was
very fun to make and this is our final
question because we did get into the
meaning of neutrinos um do you can you
think of the time in your life you
laughed the hardest harder than you've
ever laughed yes
um
in uh when i was 11
i
my parents i was born in london my dad
was working there at the time and so
they fell in love with all this british
comedy
and when i was 11
rowan atkinson had done a tour
around europe
like a couple years prior to that when i
was 11 hbo aired it as like a comedy
special
and they were like excited to see it
because they loved him and when they
were there and stuff and
i had no interest in what's that mr bean
mr b
well a lot of people know him as mr bean
but i think
his other stuff and his live stuff and
his his um his black outer is so much
more you know so much more interesting
to me than mr bean but so there was he
it was basically this one-man show that
he did he toured europe with
and i lit i went to bed that night like
i could not sleep because i could not
stop laughing so hard ed what what was
it it was ju he he he was doing he was
doing comedy in a way you know bob
newhart does the phone thing
and i had never seen that before but i
was watching rowan atkinson does this
thing where
um there was two in particular where
one was he's playing the devil and
welcoming
like a new group into hell
so it's like you know lawyers you know
whatever and and just like he you know
and then in the middle of it he'd be
like you're like
you know
uh loyal over here
and
stop screaming
you know just these little these little
accents that like of course they're in
hell they're [__] terrified but he's
just like an administrator that's
checking people off a list it's like
saint peter but in hell yeah yes exactly
so like that just that one man stuff and
his little these little slices of life
um were so just
new to me you know because i
of course like i loved when i was a kid
i loved ghostbusters and all the things
that we love when we're kids yeah this
was just like oh [__] like you can do
this yeah yeah it's interesting
yeah is it is it bill murray in
ghostbusters where he goes it's true
this man has no penis yeah
yeah i think so yeah when you said that
i immediately went to bill murray going
it's true yeah this man has no penis
that was like
talk about right on the razor's edge of
what an 11 year old could hear right
right and love and no is dirty yep yep i
feel like we weren't so precious back
then no in the 80s it did it just had to
i don't know you're absolutely right i
really do sort of worry about like this
val said it perfectly the other day
we're sort of just printing money and i
know she doesn't mean money it means
we're like flooding the market with so
much content yeah but it's almost like
this absurd we've entered into a a
season of absurdity where it's like even
watching things
you might hear a joke you've heard on
another show it's all sort of bleeding
into itself and what she means by
printing money is there's no scarcity so
you're just like
at the time it's true this man has no
penis you weren't like well that's like
seventy eight thousand other things i've
seen you're just like no i've never seen
this before i i
one of my favorite comedies of all time
is anchorman i love it i'll always love
it
the term that escalated quickly
has been so corrupted and co-opted by
so many other things
that i i cannot
in my mind if if i'm a writer or
director on a film and somebody said
that i'd be like we can't say that that
was
yeah that's the joke they used yeah so
we and
the only other app yeah that didn't
exist right that's the first time i
heard it it was funny in reference to
what had happened because it was like
this huge fight that erupted yeah and it
was a funny bit and then i see like zac
efron at the end of uh
neighbors it's like you know they're
talking about their sort of neighbor war
and he's like that escalated quickly i'm
like really you're just blatantly
stealing this line yeah from this thing
that had such a reference
in in their own thing right i'm
fascinated with the history of all
things because really i'm not not to
defend neighbors but everything sort of
like i want to see a thing about like
when's the first time you closed your
refrigerator and the and the bad guy was
right behind it or like
or we even make fun of them i thought
you're going to say opened a
refrigerator and there's a train gun
is that a thing laurel and hardy like or
whatever areas oh yeah
yeah exactly babies
or like you come home and it's dark and
someone turns on a lamp and they're
sitting in the dark yes like i i really
am interested in like break because i
bet everything
that we do like was at some like that's
got to hurt
was new yep
when they did it in the anchorman of
1938. yes that's got to hurt yeah
look out billy that's got to hurt we
widen out melanie's watching it this and
tap dance
that's how i'll be the comeback kid
he knows
um
what did what a delightful chat do you
feel satiated i do this was great do you
feel toasted like pretty hot it's hot
it's hot but i'm run hot i'm always hot
let's kill our let's kill our liquid
deaths
you didn't kill it
and would there's this is an interesting
moment because it's like wha how who do
you say keep it crispy as
because that's how we end the show the
guest says keep it crispy but i mean you
could do it i there's no shame in doing
it as andre because you know all that i
think we should just do that okay
thank you so much for being here and
we're all going to watch true lies
thank you pete
um sorry thank you pete in the time slot
and keep it crispy
i can't
just keep it claspy
thanks man thank you
[Music]
you
oh yeah